Those last few processes were probably a
bit easier than what Andy went through.
I mean, you saw the pain in his face
when the requirements changed and
when he was reflecting on the process.
If you organize things well it's
much easier to add things later, and
that's the point.
Separation of concerns is great,
especially when you do it well.
Now, sadly not all projects
are organized well.
Every company has legacy code,
even Udacity.
So how do we deal with it?
We're going to take a few minutes to
rest our brains, and we'll hear from
some experts on our software
development team here at Udacity.
They all had a ton of experience
with writing good code, but
also have to spend time bringing
legacy code up to date.
We'll talk to Nick and
Jacques about two opposing methods for
bringing code up to date.